in this video we're going to talk about
brain ventricles which are fluid field
cavity in our brain here you can see the
brain from A sagittal View and a coronal
View
so the first we'll talk about
the lateral ventricles these ventricles
are the biggest ventricle in the entire
brain there are two lateral ventricles
right in the left and these are situated
just below the corpus callosum tract
after the lateral ventricles there are
third ventricle which are situated
adjacent to the thalamus and
hypothalamus that means they are
diencephalic ventricles
so the lateral ventricle and the third
ventricle are interconnected
via the foramen of Monroe this is the
passageway of the cerebrospinal fluid
from lateral ventricle to the third
ventricle
then comes the fourth ventricle fourth
ventricle is situated adjacent to the
cerebellum
and fourth ventricle is connected to the
third ventricle with the help of
cerebral aqueduct
now this is a 3D view which shows the
lateral ventricles
then the third ventricle
and finally in the bottom you can see
the fourth ventricle
if we zoom into these ventricles we can
see it these ventricles are lined by
choroid plexus this choroid plexus
secret cerebrospinal fluid which flows
through these area around the brain and
eventually it gets absorbed so chloride
plexus is the production hub for
cerebrospinal fluid and CSF circulates
throughout the ventricles and get
collected and reabsorbed in arachnoid
granulations
there are three chloride plexus lining
the three ventricles the lateral
ventricle chloride plexus or
telencephalic choroid plexus then the
diencephalic chloride plexus which lines
the third ventricle and lastly the
fourth ventricular choroid plexus or
hindbrain chloride plexus
each of these chloride plexus can
secrete cerebrospinal fluid
cerebrospinal fluid is kind of like a
filtrate of the blood plasma
so here is a chloride epithelia here is
the blood and here is the CSF
apart from fluidy stuff CSF also has
several proteins molecules and growth
factors which regulate several functions
of the brain
CSF maintains the cranial pressure and
protects the brain from any kind of
mechanical damage
also chloride plexus forms the blood CSF
barrier it prevents any harmful
substance
entering in the brain from the blood
apart from these functions
choroplexus can also secrete important
growth factors that could drive the
differentiation of the stem cells in the
brain
in short chloride plexus secretes growth
factors that would help in the
neurogenesis program
now let's talk about
situations where the ventricle goes
bigger and this situation is known as
hydrocephalus when there is a several
time increase in the
ventricular pressure it is an enlarged
ventricle which lead to an increased
pressure in the overall brain
and that could be leading due to a
problem in the CSF circulation or let's
say overproduction of the CSF
one such example is cerebral cerebral
aquilate stenosis in this case the
cerebral Aqueduct which is the
connection between third and the fourth
ventricle is blocked that means CSF
cannot circulate freely through these
ventricles that lead to accumulation of
the CSF and production of hydrocephalus
so this is one form of obstructive
hydrocephalus so I hope this video was
useful if you like this video give it a
quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe you can follow us on
Instagram links are provided in the
description support our Channel using
super thanks see you in next video